Republicans and right-wingers are again
Furious about candy
now if this rings a bell
it's because Tucker Carlson was Furious
about candy not that long ago check out
this clip from oan where they are
Furious that M M's have gone woke by
introducing a purple Eminem
representing
inclusiveness and acceptance isn't that
just terrible right M M's you know the
candy we all grew up eating well they
released their brand new character in
over a decade and the brand new
character is purple Eminem which is
supposed to represent inclusivity and
acceptance
I think it's a female character but I'm
pretty sure they haven't said maybe it's
transgender joining me now there you go
for a very big explosive reaction to the
new Eminem's thing they focus on the
dumbest things because they completely
lack an interest and ability to talk
about actual policy issues there was
recently a headline I'm not covering I
don't know that it's a story in and of
itself but I saw a headline this morning
about how in 2017 Barack Obama was
telling uh Democrats that there's really
just no policy there's not even a
semblance of policy from Republicans
that the party is essentially a joke
that's my word not Barack Obama's and
this has been increasingly the case for
a while and these are when we say social
issues it's gone beyond social issues
it's not even about like abortion and
gay marriage anymore it's about Eminem's
and again if it rings a bell Tucker
Carlson also had a story back in January
it feels like it's been years but it was
only about 10 months ago where Tucker
was upset that the androgynous design of
M Ms was no longer turning him on quite
frankly remember this lunacy finally we
don't usually give story tips to NPR but
here's a story they might want to cover
pretty soon in doubtless will Eminem's
the candy company has just announced
that it's redesigning its cartoon
characters to be more gender inclusive
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
s were pushing intolerance but they were
they've been changed you're seeing the
changes right now on your screen the
green m m you will notice is no longer
wearing sexy boots now she's wearing
sensible sneakers why the change well
according to M M's quote we all win when
we see more women in leading roles
because leading women do not wear sexy
boots leading women wear frumpy shoes
the frumpier the better that's the rule
the other big change is that the brown
Eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block heels also less
sexy that's progress M Ms will not be
satisfied until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing and
totally androgynous until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them that's the goal when you're
totally turned off
we've achieved Equity Tucker for a long
time was really turned on by the design
of M Ms and all of a sudden they are no
longer turning him on which is a really
sad thing and woke has won apparently
guys they are focused on the dumbest
things and it is not
a glitch it is a feature not a bug
they know there's no policy left they
know they're losing on policy you ask
the American people hey should the rich
be taxed in order to ensure that nobody
Falls below a certain level of standard
of living most people agree with that
that's not good for policy when it comes
to these Republicans so instead they
talk about I'm no longer turned on by
Eminem's because of woke people that
that's that's where we are and it's not
stopping anytime soon